Greg you're here at the sci-fi London
festival tell us why you're here I am
here because I have a short in the
shorts blog called white room oh to be
three I'm what's it about it is science
fiction obviously it is about six people
that wake up in a white room they don't
know how they got there the only thing
in the room is a gun and we kind of just
observe how each person reacts to the
situation what was the idea coming from
for the film it actually came from torre
era when Mel who is a producer at
Roddenberry entertainment Roddenberry
Gene Roddenberry created Star Trek and
this is the production company that
continues his legacy and they want to do
a production that involved this new 360
technology it's just like futuristic
camera that actually shoots a 360 radius
with like an unbroken take and they
create a story that would be able to be
kind of like cinema in the round and
needed someone to design and direct it
so I came on board so how does that
affect your work as a director than
working with such interesting new
technology it was a challenge because
you know usually you think with the lens
and what the lens are seeing and when
the lens sees everything you know it
changes how you go about every single
aspect so coming from a design
background I started with the set and
worked in Word and you know usually you
have all sets essentially are three wall
sets because the cameras back is always
to one wall in this situation we had all
four walls that we were within so I had
to figure out how to like you know hide
my cables and be able to have my actors
interactive but still as a director
being on the outside of the set be able
to interact with them and but not break
their concentration because it's a
single take and there's no you know you
couldn't like clip out a piece and
change somebody if someone has a good
reaction in one take and someone flubs
in another like you can't mix and match
it was just one like live theater so how
many times did you have to go through
we did about 15 times through the entire
thing and then I asked if I could do a
traditional cut I keep saying
traditional cut I don't know if that's
even a term now that there's alternate
ways of shooting you know then the old
way is the traditional way but we did
like a one camera set up so I can do
like a director's version where I guide
the story and show each frame by frame
exactly what I want to I want the
audience to see as opposed to them being
able to see everything all the time you
mentioned that a new that your
backgrounds in design that's it's really
interesting background you've worked on
a lot of big films have I knew and
they've kind of come to the fore in this
film to haven't they tell us how they've
inspired it in terms of how you worked
and also the production design as well
um yeah I mean I've worked on a few
things I guess my resume of time I had a
terminator 2 Jurassic Park lost world AI
Minority Report Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade and you know what I do is
when I work on movies a lot of times
I'll get things when we're done stuff
that's left over you know sets pieces of
props and I have a deal with the studios
where I can't use anything in whole like
you won't see you know a control panel
from minority report but all of the
materials that I used I'm allowed to
maintain and then reconfigure them so
this particular set has walls from like
Blade Runner and real steel and just
over the years things that I've
collected and uses textures and you know
background elements to help add
production value and I think you've also
must be one of the few short films that
have had a Miss Universe painting your
fence as well how did that happen well
that's uh you know the writers wife so
you know but it makes sense i mean sci
fi you want to have a Miss Universe come
and oversee things so what could we let
food sitting next to me Greg well I
actually just directed an episode of
Felicia day's new show called written by
a kid where is
is literally that she wrangled up a
bunch of children that came in and told
stories and then each episode is a child
story with a different director and our
job is to make that story come to life
and you can pick however you you can do
it like animation or you can do it you
know stop motion and I chose to do it
live action with puppets and what's
going to happen with the white room next
because this is actually the first film
festival that you shown it at isn't it
and it and you had a little bit of a
nightmare didn't you getting it here
yeah I mean that's the thing with I mean
I guess probably even like Joss Whedon
would tell you that this weekend with
the Avengers like probably three days
ago they were you know trying to cut in
the final effects and that's they had
hundreds of millions of dollars with
low-budget you know it's no different
it's even worse we I actually got to
London before the final film did so you
know my team burned the blu-ray and
fedexed it to me so when I was sitting
in the audience watching it on the big
screen that was the first time I saw the
finished product along likely you guys
so it's a little nerve-wracking that I
have some notes or something the auto
driver change but I guess that's just
part of the game you know when you don't
don't have like you know every resource
available from a studio you just have to
roll with it and keep smiling so is it
plan now more short films or maybe
feature films even yeah I i did this
particular short because i want to work
with Roddenberry and they wanted to
experiment with the technology but I'm
more into you know features and
television so I have a couple features
planned it's this year's going so fast
so hopefully we'll get one more in this
year and in a couple next year we also
are posting one from last year called
rock jocks which I wish it was done
because it would be perfect for for this
festival it's a sci-fi comedy it's a
almost done within the next couple weeks
which probably means that it'll be out
on the market and we'll make it not
eligible for next year because people
have already seen it but but it's funny
so yeah hopefully I'll have an
they're sci-fi feature and we can come
and spend more time more than 15 minutes
that's been testing well good luck with
that when it comes out and good luck for
the next feature that hopefully will be
coming here to slide by London I hope so
I love being here
you